hey everybody it's charlie so we got a
little new trailer that they just
dropped
and an official costume reveal for barry
for that new season 5 costume remember
there was all that stuff happening a
couple days ago with the supposedly
he was saying that that wasn't the
finalized version now we actually know
what it's going to look like on screen
they released this nice shiny image
i'll also talk about the new version of
the reverse flash costume because we're
getting a new version of reverse flash
and a new costume to go with that to
boot and they confirmed another new
character that's debuting during episode
4. so i'll explain the differences in
the costume and what that means for them
going forward and what this new
character is going to be doing so if
you're brand new to the channel there's
a new round of that flash ring giveaway
all you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber leave a comment on the video
i'll name a new winner at the end of
this
biggest thing about this is that it
seems like it's chinless but like when
you zoom in
on the picture you can see a little bit
of material on the bottom of his chin
so what they may have done is just slim
down the chin strap a little bit so it
still exists
it's just imperceptible the way he's
facing the frame like this like it'll be
a little more evident when he turns his
head to the side so in the next couple
of weeks they'll probably release more
pictures as they start to drop more
trailers like they dropped that promo
that i put at the beginning of this
video
there'll be more of that in the next
couple of weeks right now they're only
getting ready to film episode 4 which is
why they announced the new character
because she's gonna debut during episode
four
but the other big thing about this suit
is that you see where
the lines are they've gotten rid of some
of the really obvious ones so they want
to make it seem more like a one piece
even though it's gonna be inside the
flash ring so like that's the cool thing
too
even though we still have the dummy i
think they're gonna find a way to
balance between flash ring in the
traditional style where he just puts it
on the dummy and then takes it off when
he wants to put it on and go help
somebody
because it is really expensive to do
that special effect like that's why you
saw it at the end of season one when the
reverse flash was pulling it out of the
flash ring and then they never did it
again
so usually they only do barry putting
the costume on in frame at super speed
once or twice during the season at the
beginning then anytime you see him in it
later or he needs to put it on
what they'll do is is he'll say okay we
need to go help somebody then they'll
just cut to a shot of him running
outside
they've almost gotten rid of all the
leather but the cowl is still leather
the cloth shoulders and back look like
it's a little more breathable so that
might be a practical thing for grant
gustin when he's just walking around in
the suit but you also have to imagine
that it's much easier to compress
and put inside the flash ring even
though the technology is a little bit
crazy the way they explain that
it's miniaturization way back during
season 2 when they got the flash ring
off the reverse flash
harrison wells from earth 2 teased that
he was going to tinker with it and then
we just never heard about it again
i can't believe something good finally
came from that suit
first and the last time i think still
gives me the creeps
we should destroy it let's do that but
see if you can figure out how to get it
back in this ring first
it might be nice to have something like
that instead of carrying around a bag
all the time
i can help you with that
what i don't think i do about micro
technology
actually i have a backup total fan
favorite
one of the things i think they were
talking about if you notice here is that
the earpieces
stick out from his ears like they do in
the comics in all the versions from
season one to season four they all
hugged his head
so they're not like full-blown mark wade
earpieces where they stick
way out of his ears like that would be a
little bit crazy but they're just
getting a little bit closer to that
so i wouldn't be surprised when we see
reverse flash show up again
if his costume is also tuned a little
bit to be more like that
i talked a little bit more about the
evolution of the flash suit in my last
video that i posted earlier this week
but we still don't know exactly what
they're going to be doing with reverse
flash only that he'll come back he'll be
a different face
the funny thing about the reverse
flashes costume on the flash tv show
is is that when matt letcher came on and
it was doing more of his season 2
character
he still wore tom cavanaugh's yellow
suit
it wasn't until he did the legion of
dewmark on legends of tomorrow season 3
that they
built him his own custom suit but it
wasn't that much different from tom
cavanaugh's version of the suit
since reverse flash is a big flash
fanboy don't be surprised if his new
costume whenever the new actor appears
looks a little bit like barry's costume
right now if you don't remember the
story of why
reverse flash made a yellow version of
the costume they actually changed that
during rebirth
now the new story is is that he was so
in love with the idea of becoming
barry's new sidekick he wanted to
replace wally west
when wally west was old enough to join
teen titans and go off and become his
own character
reverse flash had the crazy idea that he
would become barry's new sidekick that
he made his costume look like a version
of berries and yellow like wall-e's
you have to remember that current eobard
thawne as of rebirth
is more written as a toxic fanboy but i
do like the new spin on his backstory
hopefully we'll get a version of that
during season five at some point but it
depends on how old the actor is that
they recast for reverse flash
i know everybody's been wondering what
nora's secrets are if she's potentially
lying and misleading us about who she
really is
i don't think there's a whole lot there
aside from what she's not telling barry
about the bad things that she did to
cause more problems the mistakes that
she made
but because she is a flash fan girl the
way jessica parker kennedy the actress
explains her character is that she's a
real daddy's girl but the cool thing now
is that sort of sets you up
to do a fanboy version of the reverse
flash the much younger version before he
came up with the idea to track barry
down
and then eventually kill his mother so
up to this point all the versions of the
reverse flash we've seen
all two of them not counting the
alternate universe versions
or the ones right at the end of his
timeline where he finally comes up with
this grand plan to finally get rid of
barry allen but there was this whole
life that he had before that
so that's really where i think the
future of reverse flash stories are on
the flash tv show
do the younger version of eobard thon
which gives you the opportunity for a
costume
retro redesign to make it look more like
berries so that's why you know he made
it look like berries but yellow because
he wanted to be his psychic
that's why all this nora fangirl flash
stuff that they're setting up at the
beginning of season five is really
important so that down the road you can
introduce reverse flash a character that
we've seen a whole bunch but in a brand
new fresh way so that it doesn't feel
like you're telling the exact same story
the new character they're introducing an
episode for is called spin
and they're probably going to be a
combination of a couple comic book
characters
because in the comics spin was a
character that owned a global media
empire
but used another meta's powers to
control the people and make their worst
fears come true
the way the tv show describes the
character makes it sound like she'll be
using
social media to do that same thing so
she'll be making people's worst fears
come true
so because it's social media it also
sounds like it's going to be a villain
for iris as well
not sure how many times she's going to
be coming back after episode 4 but they
did say that they were introducing
younger versions of the rogues so i
don't know if that includes them doing
say like
renegades because nora's from the future
maybe people chase her down from the
future or it'll be a completely new team
with new characters and it'll just be
younger people so we'll find out more
about that when we get a little bit
closer to the season
so everybody post your reactions in the
comments below like i said we'll get a
better
idea for what it looks like when he
turns his head to the side or when they
release a promo
i don't think we're actually gonna see
any real footage of this costume in
action until they start promoting
episode two so that'll be in october
like all the footage we see from now
until episode one will be mostly episode
one stuff
i don't think he's actually getting the
costume till episode two
maybe episode three like i think the
whole thing with him wearing that season
1 costume
is only for the first episode there was
a whole bunch of other stuff to drop
recently if i have enough time tonight
i'll post more but
more coming saturday for sure so
congratulations to the latest giveaway
winner from my last big video logan
rodriguez please email me on the back
end of my channel so i can get your
contact details click here to re-watch
the season 5 trailer and click here to
learn about what disney's going to be
doing with fantastic four and x-men
inside marvel phase 4. thank you so much
for watching everybody stay awesome
i'll see you guys tonight
[Music]